GENERAL AT THE TRAIL IS NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE LEFT WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE
YOU TO STOP TALKING AND THINKING
ABOUT BAD DECISIONS I'VE MADE
OVER THE YEARS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN TO BE PROFITING FROM.
SHUT UP, THEY ARE SCREAMING.
INCLUDING TO THE SHOW.
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO, AND YOU
SHOULDN'T EITHER.
BUT FIRST, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING ONE
LAST TIME TO GET FUNDING FOR THE
PROMISED BORDER WALL ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE'S WILLING
TO SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT IN
ORDER TO GET THE FIRST 5 BILLION
IN CONSTRUCTION MONEY.
OVER THE WEEKEND, CHUCK SCHUMER
PROMISED THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE NOT THE
VOTES FOR THE WALL, IN THE HOUSE
OR THE SENATE HE'S NOT GOING TO
GET THE WALL IN ANY FORM.
>> Tucker: HE IS NOT GOING TO
GET THE WALL.
NOTICE THE PRONOUN THAT SCHUMER
USED.
DONALD TRUMP CANNOT HAVE HIS
WALL SAID THE SENATE MINORITY
LEADER.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF US?
THE OTHER 325 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT LIVE HERE?
TURNS OUT WE CAN'T HAVE A WALL,
EITHER.
IN FACT, AND BRACE YOURSELF FOR
AN ICY BLAST OF COMEDY HERE, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> WHAT WOULD IT COST TO HAVE
SCANNERS TO SCAN ALL THE
VEHICLES COMING IN?
THEY SAID $300 MILLION WHICH IS
A FAR CRY FROM 5 BILLION AND A
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE WAY TO HAVE
A SECURE BORDER.
>> MOST OF US SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF CONSIDER THE WORLD
IMMORAL, INEFFECTIVE, AND
EXPENSIVE.
>> TO SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON AN IMMORAL, INEFFECTIVE AND
EXPENSIVE WALL.
>> DON'T WASTE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY IN
ORDER TO BUILD SOMETHING THAT
WILL NOT MAKE OUR BORDER MORE
SECURE.
>> BORDER SECURITY IS ENORMOUSLY
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK BUILDING
THE WALL IS A VERY COSTLY AND
INEFFICIENT WAY TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: SO MR. MATH GUY,
BERNIE SANDERS, SAYS THE BORDER
WALL IS "A VERY COSTLY.
HOW COSTLY IS IT PRECISELY?
GET YOUR CALCULATOR OUT.
THE ESTIMATED COST OF A BORDER
WALL IS ABOUT $25 BILLION,
ESTIMATED.
SO LET'S SAY IT'S TWICE THAT.
THAT WOULD STILL BE A TINY
FRACTION OF THE PRICE OF THE
POINTLESS STALEMATE THAT WE ARE
NOW WAGING IN AFGHANISTAN WHICH
COSTS ABOUT 45 BILLION PER YEAR
NOT EVEN INCLUDING THE VAST
HUMAN COSTS.
COMPARE THAT TO THE 25 BILLION
NEEDED TO RESTORE NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY WITH THE WALL.
AND THIS IS STRANGE, NOBODY IN
WASHINGTON SEEMS TO BE UPSET
ABOUT THE PRICE OF THE
AFGHANISTAN DEBACLE.
MANY PEOPLE ARE GETTING RICH
FROM IT AND THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE.
YOU ALSO HEAR ENDLESSLY AND
USUALLY FROM PEOPLE IN GATED
COMMUNITIES THAT THE WALLS DON'T
WORK.
SO WHY IS CONGRESSMAN HAPPY TO
PAY FOR BORDER BARRIERS IN
JORDAN, TUNISIA AND ISRAEL?
NANCY PELOSI SAYS WALLS ARE
IMMORAL AND YET FOR SOME REASON
SHE'S NOT FLYING TO JERUSALEM TO
LECTURE THE ISRAELIS ON HOW THEY
ARE BUILDING THE USA.
THE ISRAELIS KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE
WALLS ARE WHICH IS WHY THEY HAVE
THEM.
THEY ALMOST COMPLETELY HALTED
IMMIGRATION.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THERE IS A
LIMIT TO THE HEIGHT OF LADDERS.
THE TRUTH AS YOU KNOW AND AS
USUAL IS PRECISELY THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT THEY ARE TELLING YOU.
THE LEFT FEARS THE BORDER WERE
ALL          WALL
PRECISELY BECAUSE IT COULD KEEP
WORKING LONG AFTER TRUMP LEAVES
OFFICE AND THAT IS WHY WHEN
PRESSED, INVARIABLY THEY FALL
BACK ON THEIR SIGNATURE ARGUMEN
ARGUMENT.
RACISM.
THE WALLS ARE RACIST.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT TO WHAT I
CALL THE BROWN MENACE THEORY.
THESE MIGRANTS ARE DIRTY PEOPLE
AND THEY BRING DISEASE.
>> THE BORDER WALL IS ABOUT
CONTROLLING THE BROWNING OF
AMERICA.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS FIXATED ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AS HE WAS
THE DAY HE ANNOUNCED THE
CAMPAIGN.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SECURING THE
BORDERS, IT'S ABOUT XENOPHOBIC,
RACIST, BIGOTED BELIEF.
>> HE BELIEVES AND MAYBE THE
FACTS WILL BEAR THIS OUT BUT
HE'S SCARED OF ANYONE WHO IS NOT
VISIBLY WHITE.
>> BASE IS SCARED.
THEY ALWAYS SAY THAT.
THEY CLING TO THINGS FOR
COMFORT.
IT'S JUST PROJECTION, LOOK
AROUND.
WHO IS ANGRY?
WHO'S YELLING?
WHO IS HYSTERICAL?
THE LEFT.
THEY DON'T WANT AN HONEST DEBATE
ABOUT IMMIGRATION OR A LOT OF